I was destined to spend the rest of my
natural life in prison crimes I didn't
commit
so journalist documentarian this is
prison saw you're going to hear a story
there's only a short period after my son
was born two months in fact my life
changed Forever on 15th December 1988 a
series of terrifying crimes took place
along the newly built M25 I was being
accused of a murder and a series of
aggravated robberies they fabricated
evidence and changed things to fit me
into the crime [ __ ] hell they
convicted us and I was destined to spend
the rest of my life in prison for the
crimes I didn't commit when I was in the
isolation cell strip naked bleeding and
bruised I screamed and I shouted through
the pain that I was suffering nobody
heard my voice at that moment something
started to grow in me that made me
become the person that I am today what
is that thing that started to grow in
you
hope free after more than a decade
Behind Bars what is a mistake that you
know you've made that you haven't yet
fixed the consequences of my actions has
meant that I've never been able to
discover anything about my son
if I put a button in front of you and
said you press this button and it raises
those 12 years I'll never ever get those
years back
did you press the button
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I can have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
this show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button I hope
you enjoy this episode
[Music]
take me back
I am if you've ever had this podcast
before I'm a huge believer that in order
to understand a person you have to
really understand their context and
their earliest context
you're from a council estate
um
your home life to me from reading
through your autobiography seemed to be
incredibly defining so take me back to
those earliest years and give me the
context I need to understand the man
that you are in your early twenties
I'll go back even further and take you
to the kind of environment that I grew
up in so I grew up in southeast London
camberwell to be precise
um just at the bottom of cold Arbor Lane
which is the kind of Junction between
Brixton and camberwell before you get to
Peckham so that kind of Circle of or
that triangle as I like to describe it
in in southeast London and it was quite
a typical
um working class environment cancerless
State and the privilege of it was that
we were all the same nobody had anything
and the other thing about that
cancerless state in the environment that
I grew up in in it was a bit of a a kind
of cul-de-sac you know in these kind of
Estates where you've got block after
block there were little roads in little
roads out onto this estate and that
little patch of grass in front of our
blocks are flat and it was quite diverse
you know I was from the mixed race
family my mum's white my dad's black you
know the floor below my flat we had the
Chinese family below that we had the
kind of overweight family and opposite
then we had the smell melee family so
there was the Scottish family over in
the other Block in the Irish family so
it was a real mix of cultures and
personalities and characters and parents
and I'm not going to say that weren't
there weren't issues and problems of
course there was and you'd always have
the shouting but there and I'm not going
to make it sound mythically like it was
a great time because it wasn't but when
you're a kid you don't recognize the
problems that your parents are facing
you're not being able to pay for the
electricity not being able to buy the
things that kids want new trainers and
stuff like that so it's quite stable but
unstable at the same time because there
was also a lot of
um
crime but not crime that was obvious to
young guys like me and the girls and you
know having a camp in the bottom of a
block of flats would be our highlight
you know we go in there put dead
mattresses in there and bits of blankets
that was my kind of environment so I
kind of grew up in this cancerous state
that was very diverse I had lots of
different cultures
um and it made me comfortable
my home life was slightly different you
know my dad is Jamaica and he was strict
he came from a very strict family back
in Jamaica so when he was in the UK kind
of brought that chip with him didn't
quite integrate into British Society was
a laborer had a strong Jamaican accent
still has a strong Jamaican accent
because he never kind of
never really kind of integrated himself
now whether that's because he couldn't
because he couldn't read and write
whether that's because he wasn't
accepted because he was a black man who
came in on the Wind rush or whether it's
because he didn't want to I've never
really found out because I've never
really had that conversation with my dad
so that's the context that's what I was
growing up in a cancerous state that was
working class and very poor
if I was if I was in the walls of your
home at that time what would have I what
would I felt it seen experienced as it
relates to the relationship you had with
your your parents was there affection
was there
was there um was there love
I think there was love but it wasn't
open love as in no cuddles I love you
kind of conversations nothing like that
took place my mum oozed care and
consideration and
um and love towards me and my three
sisters my dad was very strict he was
also a drinker I wouldn't say he was an
alcoholic but he liked to consume
alcohol and that made him aggressive and
so in my household occasionally my dad
could be physically abusive towards me
and my sisters as well as my my mother
to the point where sometimes it got so
extreme that we felt we had to flee the
home so it could be quite brutal and
he'd take it out on us so it was a
challenging household
that wasn't all the time you know my Dad
could also be a joy you know you could
be the life of the party if there was
music playing and he was slamming
dominoes and he had friends around we'd
love it because we were being exposed to
this adult world that seemed exciting
and welcoming and very different because
there was a mix between the black
culture and the white culture and for me
despite the negatives in those walls
that you talk about there was also a lot
of positives I think my dad's discipline
was born out of the idea that he thought
that was the way to get us to do the
things we needed to do to improve our
lives he had no Ambitions he had no
aspirations or anything like that and he
didn't give us any of those Ambitions or
aspirations
but I'm sure that he wanted me and my
sisters to do better than he did
I hear that
um it's a conversation I thought you
know a lot about my own mother who was
extremely
um she's from Nigeria my dad's English
um her approach towards disciplining
kids is
very uh would be frowned upon I guess is
a way of saying it
um you know I got it all
um some things I've actually never said
but I've got it all and you know as I've
grown up I've wondered was that you know
great parenting was it intentional was
it you know or was it just like a lack
of control I think it's a lack of
Education i i as a as an adult Steve I I
made a a beeline to Jamaica with my dad
I needed to understand why he was the
man that he was somebody that had never
given me a hug never given me a kiss
during my time in prison I witnessed
things with other families white
families in particular where they'd come
up to visit their son and at the end of
the visit they'd hug each other they'd
kiss each other and they'd walk off of
that visit and that inmate who I
observed getting that affection was in a
good mood I never got any of that I
would from my mum but never from my dad
my dad had a beard and I remember on one
visit on one occasion sort of reaching
out for him in the way that I saw other
people do because I'd never experienced
that to give him a kiss and it was a
kind of really awkward moment Not only
was he spared itchy and difficult but I
know that he wanted it but didn't want
it so when I went to Jamaica I went
there to see what his life was like and
I learned so much about why he was the
man that he was in the house that I grew
up in and it taught me a lot of lessons
about why my dad was the way that he he
was I can I can in some respects
understand that as it relates to you
guys you know maybe he had learned the
wrong way to to get kids to behave in a
difficult environment in a difficult
area I think uh sometimes parents
wrongly in my opinion but they think
that a more harsh approach is the right
one but then as it relates to your
mother being violent towards your mother
that to me seems a little bit more
difficult to understand using the same
explanation that it's uh
mechanism to help kids
I don't think in my household it was
anything to do with helping the kids I
think it was something he witnessed in
his own household as he was growing up I
know from what I heard when I went to
Jamaica that my dad's dad was violent
that he was abusive towards my dad and
his siblings and no doubt to my dad's
mother who died when my dad was very
young so I think it comes from a place
where he witnessed that and it was the
norm to him and he brought that into his
own life and couldn't control it
you kicked out of school at Secondary
School in my first year at my secondary
school an incident happened with a
teacher where she called me a thing you
know you think you know you shouldn't be
here kind of thing and I went home
crying and I remember my mum going to
the school having an altercation with
the teacher and slapping the teacher and
as a result of my mum being protective
now to other people that may seem like
she's assaulted a teacher But the
teacher insulted me first verbally not
physically but verbally so my mum being
the protective mother that she was came
to the school and slapped the teacher in
her face for calling her son a thing and
I got expelled to the consequences were
I got expelled and went to another
school which is now the charter school
in red post doing dulwich but it was
then called William Penn an all-boy
school and and I survived that school
for just a few years before you know my
problem surfaced more and more and I was
expelled from that school
what were your problems let's go first
I think I just couldn't set oh I I think
it was you know I I wanted more than
what the school were offering me I don't
think the schools in those days could
identify what
what kids like me who grew up on Council
Estates needed education was one thing
but we needed more I had
as I've said uh in a troubled home life
not so much that the the schools needed
to intervene I wouldn't argue it was
anywhere near as bad as that as it is in
some kids lives today and in the past
but but I needed more support and I
don't think I got any of that from my
schooling and that just allowed me to do
the things that I shouldn't be doing
which is bunking off a school not going
to my lessons getting into fights
hanging out with the wrong kids
and those wrong kids would probably be
saying hanging out with me you know so
it's kind of Vice Versa but I think it
was just doing the mundane things that
kids who are not enjoying school not
taking in the lessons that they're being
learned you know end up being kicked out
of school so I was kicked out of my
second secondary school at the age of 15
16 and they put me in what they call an
intermediate school which is basically a
kind of building where they put all kids
that they deemed to be
um you know irresponsible or or not
responsive to the education system but
what you're actually doing is just
putting a bunch of kids who are already
struggling in life and trying to
discover who they are or deal with their
their problems in one environment and
you just breed even more problems
and how did that manifest itself for you
I think I started to get in trouble with
the law I started to commit Petty crimes
shoplifting breaking into cars burglary
um some people might think that burglary
is more serious than what it was but
when you're a 16 17 year old
um you know it was just a means to an
end
so that's how it manifested itself I
started to get into trouble with the law
I remember the first time a police
officer brought me home after I got
caught Nick in curly whirly chocolate
bars from the co-op around the around
the corner from my house and it wasn't
that I needed the curly world because I
already had a drawer full of chocolate
that I pinched earlier
but it was more about I don't know you
know coming home from school going in
the shop knowing that I could do it and
get away with it was the driver I didn't
need the chocolate that I got caught and
I remember a police officer bringing me
home and I remember standing in the
front room with my dad who was fuming
and I knew I was going to get beaten for
what I did because that was his reaction
to my behavior
um and the police officer I think was
sympathetic in sort of saying you know
this is not a serious offense but it is
the beginning of something that could
become serious and he was right because
I continued to get into trouble with the
law doing nothing more serious than what
I just mentioned burglaries
um shoplifting in particular for clothes
and things that I wanted that I didn't
have the material things that we didn't
have around us in those cancellous
states that were becoming more and more
um advertised you know advertisements
you know Dairy maybe I was Nick in the
chocolate bar because they had at the
time the dairy milk chocolate ad where
the guy slide through the winter and
gives these lover a bar of chocolate and
that was my Temptation
um so that's how it manifested itself
mixing with people who were already
going down the wrong path getting
together and doing that wrong path
together
17 you you get arrested for that I got I
got arrested for burglary when I was 17
and I went to court I got arrested when
I was I think 18 maybe 17 18 for assault
I I had an altercation with a mechanic
who attacked me with a spanner because I
was giving it the big I am but he was a
man I was a boy and he attacked me but I
managed to wrestle the spanner from him
and hit him with the spanner so I was
done for Grievous bodily harm and went
to court and got a a prison sentence
which was over or a young offender's
sentence which was overturned
um so I spent just a few days in in
custody but then was out on probation
that was about as serious as it got
the knives show up in your story a few
times
um
you stab someone in the bum that was on
top of you punching you and then you got
stabbed yourself
18 years old
I lived in a world
at that point and kids live in that
world today
where carrion and knife was normalized
it was an extra
an extension of who you are an extension
of your personality an extension of your
character but most importantly I think
it was something that we did and that's
me and my friendship group and even the
enemy friendship group if you like
where they were trying to show Authority
this is something you fear you don't
just fear the person but you fear the
fact that that person may be carrying a
knife and may be willing to use the
knife and I did I used the knife I I
remember being conscious of the fact
that using a knife could cause serious
harm that didn't stop me
but it did make me realize that by using
that knife I could harm someone really
seriously hence the reason I stabbed
this individual in the buttocks the bum
rather than anywhere else
but that full circle came around and I
was attacked and having people not by
the same people no
um
you know I moved around in a group of
guys and there were lots of different
groups of guys in lots of different
areas and we were quite we had quite a
reputation the 1780 my best friend
was a known fighter he could look after
himself and I was a bit of a follower at
this age I was a bit of a follower
and he had such a freedom in his life he
grew up in the Care Homes his dad came
to England with my dad so I knew him
from when he was very young and growing
up in the care home system
he was he just had this sense of Freedom
that I wanted and I wanted it because as
I say my dad was quite a you know
disciplined guy and so if I wanted to go
out he didn't want me to go out now
whether that was because he wanted to be
mean to me or whether it was because he
was trying to protect me from what I
wanted to go and do which is to go and
hang out with guys who had no life
really but just hanging out smoking weed
and chatting up girls that's what her
life evolved around but in that
environment there were men young boys
who wanted to challenge us or we wanted
to challenge them and so inevitably it
kind of leads to you carrying a knife
and in my case using a knife and having
a knife used against me
and
from what I read I believe in your
autobiography they kidnapped you one day
and took you to a park beat you up Etc
the the boy who I stabbed in the bum he
had a older brother who was quite a
known criminal in the area in Peckham in
southeast London and he and his friends
who were older than me and my group of
friends came to my flat kicked off the
door
um
and took me in a car
to a park I was bundled in the back of
the car I was taken to a park I was
strip naked I was beaten black and blue
I thought I was gonna die I thought that
was kind of you know what was going to
happen to me I thought I was going to
die when These Guys these big guys were
kind of threatening me in the car what
they were going to do to me they
stripped me naked and they beat me black
and blue and then they left me in this
park now it was in Peckham but I didn't
know where it was because I was in the
back of the car couldn't see where I was
going ended up stopping being dragged
into this park strip naked and beaten
and this is the violent environment that
I was now involved in caught up in
but I will say this even though that
world may sound to people
like a really violent and
Disturbed world that's not who I was I
was caught up in it and I was involved
in it
but I know I wasn't that person because
it's not the person my parents were
bringing up my sisters you know are law
abiding citizens I was the black sheep
of the family I was doing things because
other people were doing things and I was
with those other people that's not me
Steve blaming other people for what I
did and the involvement that I got in
that was free will
but it just wasn't who I was I just
didn't recognize it at the time
I can completely relate to that I think
um growing up around certain
environments where people are
shoplifting breaking into things you
know in the environment that I was in in
Plymouth you know if I recounted some of
the things that we did below the age of
18 in Plymouth some of the things that
made the newspaper there was one day
where 100 of us got together with
weapons and we were going to March over
the bridge and attack the neighboring
area and all these you know things we
did because of the environment it's not
who I am but in an environment we can
bring out any side of us ourselves in an
effort to really conform and to fit in
um and as a method of Defense We join
the crowds and that's kind of what I've
heard when I when I talk about those
sort of first 18 years of your life and
those things and you you know you answer
these questions
how does it feel
I have this heat glow through my body
right now as we're talking about it
because I I'm kind of projecting myself
back to that moment and the person that
I was the environment that I grew up in
my household my friendship group and the
lack of guide and guidance and support
that young men like me wanted and I you
know I'm not a kind of bleeding heart
person who sort of says oh well there
should have been people there catching
us there should have been people there
guiding us no there shouldn't have been
um but maybe
understanding that environment as you
just say you know following in that
environment is is not always a choice
that we make because it's the only
choice
it's it's a decision that we make
because there is no alternative because
you don't know of any other alternative
and so talking about it now
um it makes me heat up inside not in an
angry way or in a passionate way but as
a reflection of the person and the life
that I led and what what got me through
that as well I think that's also
important because
in that moment at that time that I was
kicking someone or being kicked or I was
fighting with someone I was breaking
into a house or shoplifting it's the
only thing I know it was the only thing
I knew
to get money to pay for the things that
I wanted it was the only thing that the
people around me know you know rolling a
joint and smoking a joint was a bit of
fun it it we didn't think as you're not
supposed to think when you're a teenager
of the consequences and for some people
those consequences can lead to you know
dire situations as it did me or it can
lead to a New Direction in life because
they've learned a lesson and they think
right I want to go down a different path
or they meet someone who gives them an
opportunity to go down a different path
so as I think about it now I just
remember there was no alternative
there are no unknowns aren't they you
don't even know what you don't know you
don't even know that you don't know
about the other paths that are possible
if you grew up in that context where you
know there's no relatable Role Models
there's no one you can model yourself
against that's living a
other than what you said which is the TV
you get to see some people that look
like you that come from where you come
from on the TV but what I mean how many
seats are are there at that table I just
wonder whether there were people around
but I wasn't exposed to them in the same
way that there are I mean okay social
media technology is you know giving us
different platforms but I just wonder
where they were when I was in that
predicament my own predicament my own
environment where were these people and
whether it was the school teachers as I
say they were not guiding me in the
right direction yes their job is to just
educate and to impart information and I
should have been sucking up that
information like most of my peers I
suppose because not everybody who grew
up in the same environment that I did
went on to lead the same life as me so
there must have been something within my
personality and there definitely was
that made me become the person that I
become and go down the path that I went
down but I do wonder where those people
were at the time maybe they were just
living their lives outside of the
council estate and so they didn't come
into where I was because I saw very few
people become successful that were in my
immediate circle when you got stabbed
they they slashed your face didn't they
you've still got a scar from I have a
scar down the left-hand side of my cheek
I was attacked you're this is part of
the you were kidnapping the guy that's
when they that's a different incident
that was a difference that was a
different incident I was um
I was going to visit an ex-girlfriend
we'd had a bit of a rocket relationship
and I remember going to visit her in
Brixton and there were some guys
attacking an elderly woman and being the
kind of person that I was and this is
why I say there was something in me even
then
um that cared and I tried to intervene
and it led to me getting into a fight
with these guys
I didn't know they were holding a knife
I didn't have a knife with me at the
time
and they beat me one of them held me
down he stabbed me in my temple
and then cut the side of my face
open
after the fight I got up literally held
my cheek together
and made my way back to my best friend
who took me to a hospital and I had my
face stitched up by the hospital
you're 18 at this time 18.
at that age 18 were you looking out into
your future what are you saying nothing
nothing absolutely nothing just the
existence that I was in at that very
moment at that point it was about
revenge it was about finding out who did
to me what had just been done to me and
how me and my group of friends could go
and seek revenge on those individuals
especially my best friend who was my
kind of leader if you like he was the
one who was more angrier than anybody
um that's all it was about at that very
moment didn't see beyond that that's
what my existence was
at 18 as well something real life
changes in a interesting way when you um
you find out you're having a baby
yes another one of my girlfriends who
was also a young girl who grew up in the
same estate as me never really had any
kind of feelings for each other at any
point ended up in bed one night
she got pregnant
um
and gave birth to my son
at that point our relationship which
didn't exist in the first place
became even more
of a challenge because I was still a
young man myself and all of a sudden I'd
become a dad and I didn't know what a
dad was my dad wasn't as much as I love
my dad he wasn't a role model in how to
become a good dad there was no one sort
of saying to me
um this is a huge responsibility now son
and you've got to go off and do the
right thing not just for you but for
this young man that you've brought into
the world
and I was also just caught up in my own
existence and my own world I had nothing
to offer my son no guidance no money no
life
probably love but I didn't quite
understand what love meant at that point
to share with this new thing that had
come into in into my life and so a
relationship mine and my son's mother
broke down didn't exist
and that was the end of that
did you think she had been trying to
trap you
I think
I was at that age
quite quite popular among the group of
people that I was hanging around with
and
um had a bit of a reputation
um
and yeah I think
I think she you know she didn't protect
herself and I didn't protect myself and
so when we made love and had sex
didn't even recognize or realize that
she might fall pregnant but at the time
one of the one of the things that came
between us was me thinking that the
reason she got pregnant was because she
wanted to trap me into a relationship
where she could have me and no one else
could
and that became a bug bear of mine it
just made me feel that this wasn't
somebody getting pregnant because we
loved each other and we wanted to bring
a child into the world and have a happy
ever after I felt it was a
a trap that I was being brought into
this situation because she wanted me
um and that's how self-centered I was at
that age and this was actually when I
was
just before I turned just 20.
actually not 18 but just before I turned
20 because it was only
a short period after my son was born
two months in fact that I was first
arrested and charged with crimes I
didn't commit and ended up in prison so
it was only two months after he was born
that my life changed forever well you
know you weren't there when he was born
I think I read in yours I was at the
hospital the day after he was born so I
got there the day after he was born and
did what any parent dad would want to do
which is hold their newborn son daughter
and and try and I'm glad I did actually
because I think that was a moment that I
bonded with him and recognized this was
real as opposed to the months leading up
to it a pregnancy
um so I was there the day after he was
born
um and then had
limited contact over the next two months
before I ended up getting arrested and
imprisoned and then that was the end of
our relationship and this is why I say I
felt that the the the the mother of my
son
um tried to trap me because during that
period
it was I don't want anybody else to come
and visit you if you want to see that
you know there are alter maidens made to
me that I would not be able to see my
son in this I made certain decisions in
my life to cut other people out of my
life and and that kind of reinforced
this idea that I'd already had I was
being trapped into a relationship I
didn't want to be in I didn't love the
woman we had a sexual relationship and
that's all it really was and I feel
really bad saying that because the sun
come out of that and and you know as a
grown man now but I still don't have any
relationship with him as a result of my
actions not his nothing to do with him
and probably not even his mother
um but really it comes down to the
person I was at that time in my life
when was the last time you spoke to him
I've never spoke to him
I've never had the privilege of having a
conversation with him apart from when he
was still in his nap he's being brought
up to see me on a visiting table
have you tried
when I came out of prison I made
a application through the courts against
my better judgment to try and get access
to my son and I remember turning up at
court on one occasion
um as the hearings were progressing and
I think this was the kind of key hearing
and as I was walking into the call you
know the solicitors and the lawyers and
the people that were involved in this
kind of child custody case was making it
clear to me that my son didn't want to
see me his mum didn't want me to have a
relationship with him and I just felt at
that moment it would be wrong of me to
force this situation so I walked out of
the court and left it there and so I've
had no contact and I've not attempted
since then to make contact there was
this kind of little bit of me that fell
in time when he's ready he will come
looking for me for us to develop a
relationship
um sadly that's not happened
does he know who you are these days does
he know so I I think so I'm sure he does
because
he grew up in the same world that I grew
up in in southeast London um I don't
know what part of the world he's living
in right now I don't know what his life
is like what his relationships like
whether he has children whether I'm a
grandfather I have no idea and I'm
scared to even find out to be honest
there's a bit of me that's really scared
to find out that I miss so much it was a
painful
it was a painful time during the years
that I was in prison because I kept a
diary every day I'd write in that diary
every other day I'd write in that diary
a message to this son of mine that I'd
never met or had a relationship with
just so that he knew
when I got out that I hadn't completely
abandoned him physically yes I had no
control over that but in my thoughts he
was always there so I kept this diary in
the hope that one day when I got out of
prison I could present these Diaries and
he would be able to see throughout the
12 years that I was in prison that there
were lots of mentions of his names and
what I was thinking and what I was
feeling and the pain I was going through
not being able to have a relationship
with him and unfortunately I've not been
able to give him those Diaries they're
in a lot locked box at my home at the
moment
how has that been to deal with over the
years honestly how's that what's what's
that like I think I I that moment where
I walked out of the court and made the
decision that if they don't want
anything to do with me I'm not going to
force the situation I'm not gonna
get involved it might have been the
wrong decision at the time it might have
been the right decision at the time what
I didn't want to do is create a scenario
where more pain was caused and I think
forcing he would have been 12 years old
at the time forcing a 12 year old to
have a relationship with a dad that he
was told was not a good person not a
nice person didn't love you would be the
wrong thing to do and I came to terms
with that there and then and accepted
that if I was ever going to have a
relationship with this son of mine that
I'd never really got to know it would
have to be on his terms and not my term
and unfortunately those terms as far as
I know have never materialized I kind of
accepted it I kind of as sad as it is
and as much as I would advocate for any
parent and the funny thing is I will
stand and say what are you talking about
go and meet your son or your daughter it
doesn't matter that you think they don't
want to see you it's your responsibility
I've just not been able to bring myself
to do what I would tell other of people
to do because I'm scared scared of maybe
being rejected you know we all know what
that might be like going and meeting
this man and as you say he will know who
I am he will know what I do and the
success that I've made of My Life
um
but for him not to to reach out to me
maybe it's because he still doesn't want
to know who his dad is
sometimes it's as you've clearly have is
to have empathy for their situation
that's clearly what you've demonstrated
is you know
you don't you don't know I guess what
he's going through or dealing with but
you do know that if he did want to reach
out then he's probably clear on the
channels of doing doing that
I think so and there's a bit of me that
also thinks maybe he's scared maybe he's
scared that
coming to me now would be too hard a
thing I mean it's quite a dilemma isn't
it both of us at both ends
probably desperately want to rekindle
this relationship and for me to
introduce him to his brother and sister
you know my kids
um and I think about it on and off I I
do think about it I do think about how
nice that would be how lovely that would
be and you see other people make
um make those things work
but fear and being scared I don't know
you know as tough as I am in the world
that I work in when it comes to those
kind of emotional feelings
um I think it would be quite challenging
it is challenging hence I've I've not
taken the plunge I think
so
two months after his birth that's the
day that
the police kick in your door in the
middle of the night
can you take me to that to that moment
that day waking up in the middle of the
night with these men stood above you
with guns early hours of the morning I'm
I'm in bed and I'm asleep and I heard a
commotion
for five o'clock in the morning and
thought it was actually my best mate and
his brother who often had arguments and
started to walk down the stairs in my
boxer shorts teacher
um and then I saw men in balaclavas
pointing guns at me telling me to stand
still not moving really loud voices or
there shoot me
um
um I saw my brother my my best friend's
brother being taken out of the flat at
that moment
um handcuffed going backwards and my
flat mate had already been moved out
and then I was told to come downstairs I
was told to lay on the floor they put
plastic handcuffs on my hands behind my
back
um all the time sort of shouting and
threatening to shoot me if I moved
asking me whether there was anybody else
in my flat
um I didn't at that point really realize
that they were the police because there
was no police stop like you're doing the
movies it was just guys pointing guns
screaming and shouting I was
disorientated and I was taken out of my
flat and it was only at that point I
realized they were police because there
were other uniformed officers these guys
weren't uniformed officers I think
they've gone to the s17 squad or some of
the Firearms special squad or something
um so it's only when I got out onto the
landing outside of my flat and was
dragged down the stairs that I first
realized that they were the police and
at that point I saw other tenants who
were living in that Hostel at the time
also sort of face down on the floor and
as we speak about it I remember one of
my flatmates almost looking up to me
with these eyes as the police were kind
of knelt on his back and you kind of you
kind of never forget those images
they're kind of images that stick with
you at those very moments and I was
taken out of the flat and um and it was
at that point that police officers
identified themselves told me I was
being arrested for serious offenses and
then I was put in the back of a police
van
um and it was at that moment you know on
reflection at the time it was terrifying
it was horrible it was it was wrong and
even though I was involved in crime
there was nothing that warranted armed
police come into my property and
arrested me well at least I didn't think
so anyway but when I was in the back of
that police van at that very moment and
I was in the back of the van with my
best friend Michael Andy's brother
police officers opened the van and they
called Michael's name and they removed
him from the van and they called his
brother's name and they removed him from
the van and there was something really
strange about that because there was 12
13 people arrested in that flat at that
very time they were all being bundled
into different Vans but at that very
moment I was on my own
and I was on my own for the next 12
years from that very moment onwards and
there was something very indicative
about
what happened there to isolate me
into something that I I a crime that I
didn't commit and it started at that
very moment as far as I'm concerned
how long did they interrogate you for
and when did you find out the crime that
they were trying to
sort of place you against so you get
taken I was taken in this kind of all
the Vans and the police
um taken to police stations in and
around the Surrey Canterbury
um Caterham area
and I was interrogated for two or three
days it was you know after they'd taken
my property and I was
um I met a duty solicitor who came in to
one of the police cells that I was held
in who told me that I was being
um
I'd been arrested for aggravated
burglary
and other serious offenses but hadn't
told me at that point that there was a
murder a series of aggravated robberies
involved
so it was only during the interrogation
three days three days so it was on the
20th 22nd of December that I was
arrested so on the 22nd of December I
was interrogate the 23rd of December the
24th of December I was charged so it was
only during those interrogations with
these police officers that I discovered
that I was being accused of a murder and
a series of aggravated robberies that
were in relation to crimes that had been
committed around the M25 area there was
a huge amount of publicity at the time
but I was unaware of that publicity
because I wasn't a kid that paid any
attention to the news or had any
interest in what was going on in the
newspapers but at the time you know the
story of the m253 gang was on the front
page of of every National newspaper
rewards were being offered for the
arrest of these killers these monsters
as as the media were describing this
gang but I was completely oblivious to
any of that and only found out during
that interrogation that I was being
accused of murder not knowing it was
anything to do with that particular
crime and and the serious about a
robberies you know I watch a lot of
these police interrogation videos and I
always you can't help but wonder what
you would do in that situation if you
are innocent what you would say how you
would be if you're triple guessing your
own body language or
but in those interrogations when you
find out what the crime is and you
realize you have no this isn't me so I I
didn't do this I wasn't there
what are you what are you thinking and
feeling are you feeling that you're
going to be out and they're going to
they've got the wrong guy and they're
gonna realize or are you are you
terrified I think it's a combination of
both you try to hide I tried to hide my
fear and I think anybody would
when you come from it goes back to that
environment that I grew up in and my
kind of experience is if you like with
the police and you know people who are
constantly in your face kind of thing
and I think during the interrogation
there was a lot of fear I was scared
um
but at the same time I was cocky I was a
teenager I was kind of almost for the
first time in my life
standing up for myself I mean you know
standing up for myself in a fight is one
thing against my peers or people
standing up against the authority
um or authorities like police officers
is a completely different mindset but
during those interrogations during those
interviews with the police where they
started to tell me that I'd killed
somebody tell me that I was involved in
these crimes and that people were saying
that I was involved in these crimes that
I knew I was not involved in it allowed
me to be a little bit cocky [ __ ] is the
only way of describing it where I didn't
shut up and do a no commenting it's like
no what are you talking about I I didn't
do that no I wasn't there that's a lie
so I was defending myself and standing
up for myself from the very beginning
and I think
I think that
that created a situation where the
police themselves were having to to make
my life harder more difficult in that
interview room because
I I wasn't I wouldn't say roll over but
I wasn't accepting what they were
telling me I should accept and that's
not me saying that the police were
trying to get me to confess for crimes
that I didn't commit it was more about
them asserting their Authority and
telling this little brown boy with
dreadlocks who couldn't you know
articulate himself like I can with you
right now that he was a murderer that he
was a um a bad person who'd done bad
things and we've got you and we're going
to lock you up for the rest of your life
that's what I was experiencing so it was
a terrifying experience and I was scared
and I was on my own and I wasn't being
supported by the solicitor at the time
but equally at that moment during that
time something started to grow in me
that made me become the person that I am
today
what is that thing that started to grow
in you
hope
and resilience and determination and
this ability not to allow
someone else to dictate who you are what
you're going to become what you should
do what you shouldn't do
it's as if they were plant in seeds
within me my physical body and in my
mind
that would grow over the next few months
and years that I was wrongfully
imprisoned convicted of a murder and
these crimes I hadn't committed I didn't
realize it at the time but on reflection
I realized in those moments where I'd
always been a follower
followed my friends followed the
environment that I was in got involved
in things that if you'd asked me to do
it on my own I would never have done it
because I'd been too scared to do it you
know burglar house on my own you're
joking I couldn't do something like that
but when my mates were doing it yeah I'd
follow and get involved when we were
going in shops together and shoplifting
I get involved asking me to do it on my
own and I'd be quite scared to do it
and so for the first time in those
interrogations and during the early
Roman period
I became I would say a a young man and
that's where the seeds of a young man
for me started to grow when I was put in
a predicament where there was no way out
apart from drawing Within Myself the
strength that I needed to get help
and for context the crime that you were
being accused of what what exactly was
that crime
so there was a murder where a elderly
man was attacked with his boyfriend in a
field and during the course of that
attack he died of a heart attack having
suffered a beat in from this gang of
three men
the same three men that were involved in
that attack that hijacking
of a car where the car was hijacked by
three men the man was beaten the same
three men then turned up at the property
of some wealthy people in Surrey broke
into their home tied up the occupants
attacked and stabbed one of the
occupants
and then they fled that crime in the
cars from that property and went to a
third scene all in one night all over
the 15th 16th of December 1988 they then
went to another crime scene broke into
the property of
um two occupants and tied up those
occupants and fled with their property
so those were the free crimes murder
attempted murder the stabbing and the
aggravated robbery and then the third
aggravated robbery at the final
scene so all of those crimes is what I
was being accused of being involved in
as your Center sentencing in so that the
case approached were you hopeful were
you hopeful that you were going to be
found not guilty and be able to walk it
wasn't Steve about whether I was hopeful
or or
um you know what I felt it was about the
evidence it was about the information
that was available to everybody that was
involved in this case and by that I mean
me my co-defendants and the lawyers that
were defending and Prosecuting what was
available through the victims of the
crimes and you know just before and it's
important to mention just before I was
arrested and we talked about or I talked
about the headlines that were in the
newspapers that I was not privy to at
the time there were calls for the the
police to arrest the two white men and
one black man that were responsible for
these crimes and those detailed
descriptions of the perpetrators who
were involved in the murder in the
series of robberies came from the
victims of these crimes not just one
victim at one scene but the crimes I
just described at three different
locations each of the victims at those
scenes described
two white men and a black man one victim
went so far as to say one of the white
men had blue eyes and fair hair because
they saw that through the balaclava that
they were wearing and they were up close
this is not fleeting sort of CSI kind of
identifications where you can say out
where they may have made a mistake all
three victims have three completely
separate crimes had given descriptions
to the police which were then relayed in
the newspapers the news the world front
page you know I came face to face with
the kill for kicks gangs that were the
kind of headlines as Witnesses saw the
men attempting to burn the cars from one
of the robberies the two white men
standing by the car terrify me so I
called the police you know these were
Witnesses
outside of the victims who identified
white men so the fact that myself Brown
guy brown eyes dreadlocks my best mate
black guy brown eyes dreadlocks and my
third co-defendant who was arrested
slightly later than I was African black
guy
none of us fitted the descriptions that
the victims and the witnesses knew were
responsible for these crimes yeah I was
charged
I was tried I stood in the dock when the
victims came into court looked at me and
my co-defendants who still had these
dreadlocks and I'd had these dreadlocks
for years
looked at us in the dark
and knew must have known that we were
not responsible for the crimes that were
perpetrated against them
and yet
when they told the jury
that the descriptions of the men were
too white and one black their conviction
was not as it should have been
and by that I would argue that the
police started to undermine their story
to secure the convictions that they
needed to secure so when I talk about
and you asked the question and was I
hopeful at this point that
you know things would be
um successful at the trial I should
never have been charged let alone held
on remind in a prison within a prison in
Brixton for 18 months and let alone
dragged into the dock to face these
charges when everybody involved in the
case knew we could not and did not
commit these crimes so yes I was
confident when we were in the dark that
the 12 men and women that would judge us
would conclude that this is a racist
unjust trial and they would be on our
side but they weren't they convicted us
and I was destined to spend the rest of
my life in prison for the crimes I
didn't commit
that moment when you hear
the verdict
what what happens in your mind what how
did what's that moment like it's hard to
reflect back I know that being a young
volatile man I was even though I'd
learned some self-control and discipline
because I practice yoga in those 18
months of being banged up in a Cell for
23 hours a day that kept me going and
practicing Taekwondo and doing in cell
press-ups and all that so as well as
physically preparing my body physically
to withstand the onslaught of the trial
um when I was in that dark I think
I think again and I talk about those
seeds that were planted in me during
that interrogation time and what I
discovered during the 18 months that I
was in this prison within a prison I
think when that verdict came in
um as well as exploding and screaming
and shouting and my parents family and
supporters were angry
I just want you to fight everything and
everyone for what was happening to me
I'd already put up a lot of resistance
but there was a little [ __ ] that made
me believe that it just couldn't happen
they couldn't convince me to send me to
prison for crimes I didn't commit of
such a serious nature
um so as well as being volatile at that
very moment I continue to be volatile
for the next God knows how many years
and the only person
that suffered was me I was the only
person that suffered spending years in
isolation segregation being beaten
physically by prison guards who were not
responsible for my wrongful conviction
but they were the authorities keeping me
in prison even though that's their job
but I didn't recognize that at the time
so when I heard that verdict
it put a seed in me again that said nah
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna let you do
this I'm not gonna sit back and suffer
this why should I why should my family
why should you get away with this no I'm
not going to allow that to happen and
that became that seed that grew me in
the years that followed and what was the
the sentence
I was sentenced to life imprisonment for
the murder
I was sentenced to 15 years for the
attempted murder
I was sentenced to 12 years for the
attempted murder aggravated robbery I
was sentenced to 12 years for the
assault on the guy that was with the guy
that died and another 12 years for the
final robbery
total in life plus 56 years I think if
my calculations are right but in reality
my sentence was life never to be
released because when you get a life
sentence if you maintain your innocence
and you don't conform to the regime and
jump through the Hoops of
accepting guilt you don't get released
not when I was locked up in prison I
think things may have changed now
because people recognize that the system
gets things wrong and people have been
released despite the fact they've
continuously protested their innocence
many years after you know their
convictions or or sentence has been
served life since in this country can
mean anything from 12 Years to 30 years
but I was destined to spend the rest of
my natural life in prison for crimes I
didn't commit
you know this um this podcast is
streamed in prisons did they tell you
I have a lot of supporters in prison
really I do uh actually I think people
admire the work that I do having come
out of prison from that predicament and
go on to try and advocate for prisons
prisoners but not just people who but
also representing the families and the
victims and everybody and anyone that's
involved
in this space because of the scars you
know seeing my physical stars but you
know there's a lot of kind of emotion on
internal scars that I carry from from
that time in prison so it's great to
know
that any prisoner listening to this
story sitting in a Cell believing that
they're innocent or even guilty but not
seeing a light at the end of the tunnel
take it from me there is a [ __ ] light
at the end of the tunnel if only you use
your time constructively if you sit on
your bed sitting yourself look at the
bars and don't do something to change
the person that put you in prison
especially the guilty ones they're just
going to end up
back in prison or your destiny is gonna
fall flat if you have any Destiny use
the time constructively that would be my
argument to any guy in prison listening
to this because you can you have at your
disposal well a lot of people in this
world don't have a nice time [ __ ] me
they have some time you know not just
for reflection but to use it
constructively I went to um I went to
one of the prisons that streams the
podcast so we did a deal with Her
Majesty's prison service where
um they have a screen in their cell and
they can watch this podcast in these
conversations and I got to go a couple
of weeks ago two weeks ago I think it is
maybe three weeks ago and see meet the
prisoners talk to them go into the side
their cells they told me about the
different episodes they've been watching
I get feedback as well from it on the
episodes which is amazing but it was um
it was a really you're totally wrong
what you said about the time thing I
could see how
they have the thing that so much of you
know in terms of time that we find in
our very busy lives we're always trying
to find a couple more minutes more they
were using their time in the most
amazing sometimes incredibly inspiring
ways I got handed business plans that I
literally have upstairs you know I saw
crafts things they'd made out of soap
that I couldn't believe were were
possible
um but it but but at the same time there
was um a real feeling that these these
young men were at a very important
Crossroads
and that's I think that's what sort of
stunned me into silence as I left was I
could see
Crossroads quite clearly and it goes
back to what you said at the start of
this conversation where I felt with some
of them that were that wanted to to
better themselves or at least told me
they wanted to bet themselves they were
lacking like role models in the context
back home or information on how to once
they returned to the environment they'd
come from how to create that life
and that was the thing that I really
struggled with I almost fought a
responsibility leaving there thinking
how can what can I do to help that young
kid who's handed me this business plan
which is amazing because clearly he
spent so much time on it but I know that
when he leaves the system he's going to
fall back into an environment where
there isn't entrepreneurs and there
isn't anybody to tell them how to start
that business or whatever it might be
you know support my Foundation that's
what you should yeah
but but the important thing is during my
time inside I I didn't study the law but
I got to know what the law was all about
because I needed to fight my wrongful
convictions by understanding the law
journalists were writing stories about
me being a monster the Sun newspaper was
calling for hanging to be brought back
and if they had their way I wouldn't be
sitting here talking to you today
because I would have been hung strung up
for a crime I didn't commit and then
pardoned 10 15 years later when they
recognize my innocence fortunately I was
shrewd enough and this would be my
message to prisoners to be shrewd enough
that I studied a correspondence
journalism course in prison because I
knew I needed the media to tell you and
other people on the outside world that I
was innocent so I studied the media to
understand how the media worked so that
I could plant stories in newspapers
National newspapers challenging issues
to do with prison or disclosure of
evidence or conviction so not
specifically about my case although that
was my ultimate motive it was about
understanding how journalists work and
then using those journalists to get my
message out there and so that would be
my argument that guy's giving you their
giving you their kind of business plan
why give it to you why not take that
business plan understand it themselves
and do it for themselves yes they do
need somebody to offer them a space or a
piece of opportunity but they need to do
it for themselves and that's what I
learned during those early years or late
years that I was in prison that you
cannot rely on one person to dig you out
or or help you out of the situation you
have to do it yourself which is why I
say these seeds that were planted in me
from the beginning they grew into the
resilience the determination you know
hope which is you know
everyone has a Story Don't They about
hope you know how we listen to other
people it's
um it's a self-determination that you
can only find when you when you discover
yourself in a situation that you cannot
control you have no control over but you
can control what you do for yourself
giving you their business plan hoping
that you will do something for them
would be great but you can't do it for
everyone so they have to do it for
themselves
if I'd asked you then say a couple of
years into your
um your sentence if you were going to
spend the rest of your life in prison
what would you have said to me
no
I was never going to spend the rest of
my life in prison for a crime I didn't
commit
I was not going to come out there in a
box
I was not going to let them kill me and
there have been and was occasions where
prison officers beat me so badly
the easiest way to get through it would
have been to die
um
I was not going to spend the rest of my
life in prison because I was going to
fight for my freed initially I thought
it was the physical fight that was going
to get me there confronting the prison
office as fighting prisoners you know
getting involved in volatile violent
situations was my way out that was
really just me
escaping the reality of the suffering
that I was going through inflicting pain
on others being inflicted pain on me was
a way of kind of dampening that pain
that suffering it wasn't until I started
to educate myself around the areas I
needed to educate myself and also grow
up and become more wiser and listening
to the wiser guys who had spent many
many years in prison and were telling me
don't do it the way you're doing it you
will not get out some high profile
miscarriage of Justice individuals who
have been successful in their own
campaigns were telling me you can't do
it the way that you're doing it you need
to you know get the tools pens and paper
I remember having my first tick tick
typewriter you know tick tick tick in
myself that's what we're dealing with
there was no internet there was no
emails there was no mobile phones or
anything like that I was doing it with
the raw materials you know tick tick
tick made a spelling mistake how came
the tip X I go through the tip X and sit
because I had time wait for it to
[ __ ] dry and then I could take over
it again and carry on writing the
document that I was writing so you can
imagine one piece of paper I'm writing
an application to European call 200
pages long can you imagine how long that
took me on a bloody typewriter because
there were no computers and no access to
anything but that typewriter I can't
remember who I got that typewriter from
or where it came from but I'm truly
grateful because not only did it give me
the tool to fight my wrongful conviction
but it allowed me
to understand myself and to learn from
myself how to use new words how to
articulate myself how to express myself
how to win an argument how to change a
situation
um and that's what I did in that time
that I was and and we're talking seven
eight years into my prison sentence now
so no I was never going to spend the
rest of my life in prison because I was
gonna fight for my freedom until I was
freed and I did and I won one of the
things I read was was how one day you
saw someone
had taken their own life in one of the
cells
um near yours
you know the
the burden of having to deal with you
know being convicted for a crime you
didn't commit is one thing but then
having have being exposed to these kind
of things in a as a Young Man
these are images that I imagine don't
ever sort of leave your
leave your mind unfortunately
no
um this was an elderly black guy been in
prison probably 20 years
for murder
he was hoping that he would get released
and he got a letter
um you know people ignored him he's the
kind of guy that you kind of walked past
most of the time and you might give him
a little bit of burn cigarettes for him
to smoke or something but he's one of
those guys that you kind of you know
he's there but he's not imposing or
anything
but he got that letter from the parole
board that denied him the next
opportunity to be released
and after 20 odd years in prison he knew
that he was destined to spend probably
another five or ten years in prison
um and he took his life
he hung himself and he killed himself
it's not the first time
that I saw somebody
die in fact I saved a guy's life
when I was in one of the last prisons
that I was in I became a gym orderly
somebody that helped other people PE
instructor you could say within prison
the only job I would do
and so I would be let out of myself
slightly earlier than most guys and I
was let out of myself doing my thing
going down to the gymnasium and I was
walking past a guy's cell and I saw his
legs dangling
and I run into the cell and I grabbed
his legs and I lifted him up and he was
you know doing as you do you you he was
shaking and I managed to get him down
didn't know what to do you know he
didn't die he recovered I went to the
gym
on my way back
he was quite rude actually because I
saved his life he wasn't grateful or
thankful
um and it was an awkward one because I
thought
I saved this guy's life I did what
anybody would have done
and the strange thing is he just got on
with it
he didn't
nobody knew nobody knew what he'd
attempted except me because I stopped
him from doing what he was doing I never
found out why he attempted to to take
his own life
but you live with those stories never
having an answer and that's prison for
you there are people in an horrific
things and you know they've done
horrific things and there are people in
there who shouldn't be there not because
they're innocent simply because they did
what they did to survive or to provide
for their family
but you never know why you never get the
real answers because some people are
just not prepared to share it
what was this about
the police paying some witnesses or
paying someone to
to give false evidence that I that I was
reading it was at the time that the
police were hunting this gang a reward
put up five thousand pounds in 1988 a
lot of money 20 000 pounds by The Daily
Mail making the reward 25 000 pounds
and so the
Theory and I say it's Theory because
we've never been given the documents to
prove what we know is true so the theory
is that one of the key Witnesses in my
case who gave evidence against me that
led to my convictions was one of my
ex-girlfriends alongside her was a white
guy who was a suspect at one point the
only person in the case with blue eyes
and fair hair which fitted the
description of the perpetrator but he
was a known police Informer and worked
on other cases with the police so there
was a conclusion that he
and this girlfriend of mine were paid
that reward money to give Force evidence
and that was part of the evidence that
we presented to the European Court of
Human Rights and they said that the
prosecution of the police and the Daily
Mail need to disclose whether these
Witnesses did get this money because if
they did it would explain their
incentive to tell lies so the girlfriend
for example just to put this into
context when I was on remand and she was
my alibi as well as a prosecution
witness so I was in bed making love with
her on the night that these crimes were
being committed I was in bed making love
with her at the very moment that the
murder was being committed some 40 miles
away from where I lived
despite that alibaya was still convicted
so if you think the identification issue
is
outrageous the fact that I was in bed
with a girlfriend making love at the
time the murder was committed she tells
the police that the prosecution except
that but then say it's a mystery how I
got to the scene of the crime there's no
mystery I wasn't there
she sent me a letter
when I was on remand in Brixton prison
apologizing for the lies that she told
and the lies that she told
for the police was that I left her at 1
30 in the morning after we made love the
murder had already been committed by 11
o'clock that night the first Robbie had
already been committed by half past 12
so even on her lies
it still didn't allow for me to be a
part of this gang and a part of these
crimes so when she sent me this letter
Brixton prison I presented it to my
defense the prosecution become aware of
it
and we believe that she was paid a
reward to
say that
she sent me that letter because she
wanted to help me and it wasn't true
so the reward we believe was paid to her
to tell lies for the police and to this
police Informer for him to tell lies
and we still believe that today despite
the fact that the prosecution using
public interest in community
certificates are these kind of secret
documents of still to this day never
disclosed who got that reward money I
wrote to the Daily Mail and said you
paid this money to these Witnesses who
have been told who have told lies you
paid this money to a witness who was a
key suspect and could be responsible for
these crimes surely there is an onus and
a responsibility on you the Daily Mail
to disclose this information and they
never did to this day
and did you ever write to her and ask
her if she received the money no I
didn't know how to and I didn't
I didn't feel that was that was
necessary I I knew she lied she knew she
lied
um we got when the rough Justice program
was made they secretly recorded the guy
on their show admitted that he conspired
with the police this was one of the key
pieces of new information that rough
Justice broadcast but they secretly
recorded this witness admitting to them
that he'd fabricated evidence for the
police in the M25 case he didn't know
that they were secretly recording that
conversation for the program they were
making about my case and so that in
itself became a key piece of evidence
but I never
from my conviction to this day had any
contact with the ex-girlfriend or that
guy who we know told lies
I read this other quite quite funny in
some ways quite perverse in other ways
story about a chaplain
you know what I'm gonna say yes I do
bizarre things happen in prison with
bizarre people and we benefit from it
I mean you can tell the story
for those who want to hear this story is
about a chaplain right so prison is a
place where you don't have conjugal
visits I.E you know married men and
women who are in prison are not entitled
to have any intimacy with their husband
wife girlfriends when they're in prison
that's just not how it works in this
country in other countries it does but
in this country it doesn't but there are
some people in prison including this
chaplain in this particular prison who
had sympathy for prisoners he had an
understanding that intimacy an
opportunity for intimacy was limited and
so
um if and we prisoners knew this if you
could get your loved one outside
girlfriend outside or someone you wanted
to have sex with outside write the
chaplain a letter to say to the chaplain
that you are thinking about dumping your
boyfriend or you get that letter and
take it to the chaplain and say I've
just received this Dear John a Dear John
being a letter from a girlfriend or a
loved one outside saying that they don't
want anything more to do with you and
that you need a private visit a visit
that is not in the visitings hall with
everybody else but maybe in a you know
quieter place and so this chaplain was
known for helping people out in this way
so he would allow people to book this
private visit where they would have
their
um their loved one come in their
girlfriends or their wives come in
but what he had was a hole in the wall
and what he did is he used to spy on
people who were in those private visits
who took those opportunities to have a
quick bit of sex and he was spying on
him and they discovered that he had this
hole in the wall and was watching
prisoners have sex with their wives or
girlfriends during these encounters now
I would argue that most prisoners
wouldn't care less because I was one of
those prisoners and after 10 years for
the first time I was able to have
intimacy to the point where I came in
you know nanoseconds kind of thing I
know I detailed too much but the reality
is is when you've been wanking for so
many years and you've not had any
intimacy it is a real hard thing not to
not come in seconds but but to rekindle
those kind of relationships you know how
to become intimate with somebody when
you've been deprived of that for so long
how you and as I said at the beginning
of this you know I wasn't somebody who
had people coming up on the visit me big
hugs and Cuddles so it was a real real
challenge just one of the challenges
that you face at the end of being in
prison and there are many many more the
psychological as well as the the
physical but I was privileged to be in
one of those rooms on one of these
occasions would I have reported that
chaplain that he was watching me no I
wouldn't I would have used it to get
another visit but unfortunately somebody
did grass on him and so he was removed
from the prison system and that
privilege that the prison officers
didn't know about
stopped was it was he a priest or
something was he a he was a priest who
worked in the prison and how is he
getting getting these women in so this
was one of your ex-girlfriends so he
wasn't he wasn't smuggling I mean or
anything like that so they would come
through the normal visiting channels but
you would have approval from the priest
or the chaplain to have this visit not
in the normal visiting Hall but in the
chapel as a religious no it's not even
religious but they have a chapel in
prison where people can go and they can
practice their religions but they would
have rooms in there
um you know it might be his office in on
this occasion it was like a communal
area that the chaplains see and people
coming in to visit him on official visit
would sit down and have a cup of tea and
whatever I was in the room with my
kind of pen pal girlfriend if you like
at the time
um I'm going to give you the graphic
detail because it's important so you you
know we're kind of doing it we're kind
of like I'm kind of going at it that no
no second time and he walked into the
room
um as I was kind of mid flow if you like
and picked up the tea and biscuits or he
dropped off or picked up I can't
remember if we dropped off the tea and
biscuits but he didn't bat an eyelid he
literally just came into the room we
were kind of about to kind of react in a
way but we didn't have any time he just
literally came in picked up the tray or
dropped off the tray and just walked
straight back out
so he was
well aware that anybody he agreed to
give one of those visits
it would be an opportunity and I thought
it was a great thing you know there are
not many people in prison who have
sympathy for prisoners or would do
something to allow them A Moment Like I
was allowed on on that occasion and
after such a long time of no intimacy
um
I was grateful for it gutted that he
lost his job
I'm sure people have a lot of mixed
feelings about it so I haven't I won't
comment on uh on my own views but I'm
sure people have a lot of different
mixed opinions on on that and the kind
of perverse Behavior quick one as you
might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when I put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is
um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made quick one from
our longest standing sponsor hero I I
can't tell you over the last I'd say
over the last really it's been about two
and a half years it was really um post
pandemic how much my health has become
such a huge priority in my life huel has
been probably the most important partner
in my health Journey because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and that's why it's such a
wonderful thing to be able to talk to
this audience about a brand and a
product that is so unbelievably linked
to my values and the place I am in my
life are valuing the gym exercise
movement my mind my breathing and all of
those things and most importantly my
nutrition that is the role fuel plays
and so every time I get to read these
ads out I do it with such passion
because I really really believe every
word I'm saying and I absolutely love
the brand so if you haven't already
tried Hill and you've been resistant to
my my pestering then give it a go and
let me know how you get on what was the
first Domino that fell that ultimately
led to your release I think it was the
BBC rough Justice program so this is a
program that used to exist on Prime Time
BBC one and it was a program where
journalists investigated potential
miscarriages of justice and I'd had
journalists at this point already visit
me in prison and as you rightly say when
I made those calls or spoke to them when
I shouldn't have spoke to them I used to
get punished for it because there was a
policy you know where prisoners were not
allowed to talk to journalists and tell
journalists and their stories not
necessarily because they were victims of
a miscarriage of Justice it just wasn't
allowed because it was something to
protect victims but it was really when
after journalists have started to write
stories about me so my tack my tactic if
you like of understanding journalism
started to work I was getting
journalists coming to meet me they were
starting to question the safety of my
question and my conviction or at least
writing stories about who I was you know
10 years on you know the person that was
deemed a monster the person that was
supposed to be the leader of this M25
gang Etc
but I was sitting on the toilet
in my cell in Kingston prison and we had
this little TV monitor mobile phones
didn't still exist at this point so
there were TVs on these little kind of
boxes and there was one circling away
circulating around the prison and it was
um it was given to me that night because
the BBC rough Justice program were about
to broadcast now a long investigation
into my wrongful convictions that was
the first Domino I think that was
where a credible platform like the BBC
um with serious journalists who knew
their stuff took these things serious
started to question my conviction and
that led to another launch of other
media Outlets taking an interest but the
application I told you about that I
tapped on my type prior to European
Court of Human Rights was I think the
final straw because when
21 judges at the European Court of Human
Rights unanimously concluded that I was
denied the right to a fair trial because
the police had conspired with Witnesses
and suppressed evidence and there were
questions about the identity of the true
perpetrators when those 21 judges told
the British court system to re-look at
my conviction that was the kind of final
straw and I knew then that my
convictions were going to be overturned
take me to the the moment that you found
out that you were going to be released
and what
the context that brought brought you to
that moment well I've just talked about
the the European Court decision so the
unanimous decision from the judge is
that judgment came down my lawyers were
kind of bouncing up and down saying this
is it this is the moment the appeal call
and the Home Secretary I mean I've been
on hunger strike and did many other
little stunts
that were quite serious to to my own
well-being and and health to try and
draw attention to my plight if only to
get journalists to to tell other people
what I was going through in the hope
that other people would support me and
it worked they did and they made enough
noise for the politicians and the system
to understand that there was this guy
who'd been in prison for many years for
a serious offense that he didn't commit
who was not giving up and it worked
because even the prison guards were now
slipping newspapers under my door with
the article and banging on my door and
saying good luck you know a couple of
years earlier they were
banging open my door and dragging me
down the segregation block and giving me
a kick in because in their eyes I was a
convicted guilty man who was just making
trouble for the prison system and so by
the time I
I got to the court of appeal so I taken
from Kingston prison in Portsmouth
brought to Pentonville prison in London
met up with my co-defendant for the
first time in many years Michael and the
other co-defendant we went into the
appeal call and there was this
three-week hearing in front of some
senior judges about the Rights and
Wrongs of the evidence non-disclosure of
evidence payment of rewards issue around
identification so the whole case just
between my defense lawyer the
prosecution then the judges was played
out almost like it was at the original
trial only now there was far more
information there was a European Court
decision there was a secret recording
from the BBC rough Justice programs all
this was being played out and there was
a lot of attention from journalists only
this time on my side as opposed to you
know writing that I'm a monster and
everything so we went over the
journalists and we're also concerned
about our convictions
um but even on the last day of that
hearing the judges were pretty cruel
actually in that they didn't make a
decision there and then they knew they
were going to push my conviction they
knew as did the prosecutor they knew
that they couldn't withhold this
conviction anymore but what they did is
they reserved judgment and despite my
defense Barrister saying well you know
you should be freeing these men at least
on bow until that judgment is made they
didn't and so I was dragged back down to
the courts and taken back to the prison
where I waited for another
and this was in the year 2000 where I
waited for another
few months a few weeks sorry before I
got that knock on my cell door from the
governor saying can you come down I've
got something to tell you your case
decision is coming in tomorrow so we
need to take you back down to London
today
and I walked
um up those steps at the court of appeal
on the very last day the judges quashed
my convictions made some derogatory
remarks about the safety or non-safety
of my convictions but it was over my
convictions were quashed and
um
at that moment it's hard to describe how
I felt because I didn't feel anything I
really didn't feel anything until I was
taken back down the stairs
they did something that I was unable to
do in all those years that I was in
prison and that was open that the last
door
that didn't have a handle on the inside
so in all the years that I was in prison
I never opened a door for myself so this
last door down in the dungeons of the
court of appeal in central London was
opened by prison officer for the last
time and I knew that I was walking out
of that door
didn't think about it at that very
moment the normal reflection and
realizing that that door that was being
open would be the last door that I
wouldn't be able to open for myself
and when I walked out of the
court of appeal door and I saw my
sisters my mum and my supporters
I I was able to fall into the arms of my
younger sister who was my most my
biggest Advocate and cry for the very
first time
um and at that moment
the the anger and the bitterness and the
the volatility in me and and everything
that that got me through those 12 years
almost fell off me onto the floor in
those tears
um
and that changed me
almost instantly
and that was probably
it was the only time I'd cried in all
those 12 years since I'd been wrongly
convicted
it was also the first time where I
probably relaxed you know the threat of
violence in prison is always there the
dangers that come with
being in prison
um the lack of having anything and and
all the the big things like not being
able to open a door or make decisions
and choices for yourself all of that was
lifted from me at that very moment
where I
I would argue I I'd one bet my freedom I
fought so [ __ ] hard for my freedom at
that moment I'd want it my sister wanted
my mum my dad my other sisters my
campaigners the journalists all those
people that came on my side my family
were always there but all these other
people that were now on my side together
we walked to the front of the court of
appeal
and I'm waving my fist and I'm shouting
you know I spent all of my 20s locked up
in maximum security prisons in Britain
for crimes that I didn't commit the best
years of my life I don't know what I
would have become Steve as you asked me
at the beginning but what I do know is
that in those 20 years I could have
become anything I I could have met a
person and been offered an opportunity I
could have been dead I could have been
anything
but what I was was
wrongfully convicted and imprisoned for
12 years where I couldn't love anyone
couldn't kiss anyone couldn't hug anyone
couldn't do the things that people were
doing in their twenties you know
developing friendships relationships
none of that was afforded to me so when
I walked down those steps and I shouted
in the media because there was interest
in in my convictions being overturned
that they'd stolen those years all of
that was a release
for what happened next in my life
did they ever
say you were innocent the criminal
justice system did they ever by quashing
my conviction they
accepted that the evidence against me
was unsafe as I said when the judge
quashed my convictions and made comments
about no Declaration of Innocence or
this is not a judgment of of Innocence
well who puts them in a position to make
those kind of decisions but it was
typical of the kind of racist system
that I'd experienced we'd beaten the
system we'd shown them that they'd
locked up three black men for a crime
and crimes they didn't commit and they
just could not accept that and so their
final word at the appeal court to try
and damage
or limit the damage that he had done to
the criminal justice system was to say
something that would make journalists
question whether
these men should be released or
shouldn't be released but the simple
fact that the judges had reached the
conclusion that our convictions were
unsafe the simple fact that they quash
my convictions and released me from the
hell hole that I'd been in for the last
12 years was indicative that they knew
because they'd already rejected my
appeal many years ago and for years on
they wouldn't hear my appeal
so there was a damage limitation
and if they really in my view if they
really believe people are guilty in
prison regardless of the information and
evidence they don't release them you
don't get out the court of appeal is one
of the hardest places to get your
convictions overturned
so when I walked out despite the judge's
reservations and the Court's
reservations
I was released an innocent man they
recognized that the home office have a
criteria
where they only compensate people who
are innocent and I was compensated for
the years that I was in prison the rules
have changed now and they don't
compensate people have been wrongly
convicted miscarriage of Justice victims
um unless there is some insurmountable
information where they have an
obligation and I don't quite know how it
understands but it was indicative when
the Home Secretary in my case the new
Home Secretary I think it was Jack straw
at the time
um
agreed to compensate us ridiculous
amounts of money not as in wealthy they
can never compensate me for a day of my
life in prison let alone 12 years
but it was again another indication and
a Vindication of our years of being
wrongly imprisoned when I've read
through all of your research I was
wondering about this I was wondering if
there was ever a a first of all
they were clear that they came out and
said you're innocent which I think is
really really important because it was
kind of ambiguous that the statement
there's no ambiguity here my convictions
were quash and I was freed as an
innocent man judges comments it was an
apology mate a judge's comments that
made it seem like they were trying not
to
well again it was that damage limitation
it was judges sort of saying you know
these convictions are unsafe and we're
releasing these men but we're not saying
they're innocent yeah that bit which I
think is a bit of a [ __ ] thing to do
if you just admit that the case is not
just can't stand but that's the system
we work under yeah you know to confit
three black men when the qurans were
committed by two white and one black man
that in itself is indicative of how
unfair our system is and that was
another indication and an apology I was
trying to figure out if there was an
apology from someone
I got an apology about a year and a half
ago from a senior police officer who I
interviewed on my podcast
um for the Metropolitan Police and he
that's the only apology I've ever had
I've never had an apology from the
course I've never had an apology from
the criminal justice system per se but I
did get an apology it was more of a kind
of like raffle lovely beat you and I'm
really sorry what happened to you so
from that side of the world that was
probably the only time someone said
sorry to me but I don't need sorries I
don't want sorry I can't get me but my
12 years of 12 million sorrys it just
doesn't work for me and then the last
point was compensation which was
obviously they as you said they can't
compensate they don't compensate it's a
policy they do not accommodate I mean
even if they gave you a gazillion pound
it doesn't compensate for taking time
trust me but they gave you decent a
decent compensation as in like a big
monetary number they give you a a I
won't say the figure but they do give
you
um you know tens of thousands of pounds
okay which is
um an amount that they deem to be
depending on your circles Nancy if I was
you and ended up in prison because of
all the loss they'd probably have to
give you lots of money I probably
wouldn't give you anything that you're
worth or that you've yeah so it's
relative to it's relative to what your
circumstance is and then they charge you
for bed and board [ __ ] so I spent 12
years in prison for a crime I didn't
commit and then out of my compensation
they deduct
bed and board bed and lodgings so I've
got my [ __ ] compensation they then
talk so they give me a lump sum so let's
say they give me a hundred thousand
pounds from that hundred thousand pounds
they calculate how much it would have
cost me to pay rent in a single room in
a flat and then they deduct it from your
compensation
psychological psychiatric any kind of
help that you need mentally or even
physically or even your health that is
deteriorated in those years in prison
they then put that within your
compensation don't give you extra to go
and get psychological or psychiatric
help which is something that I think
anybody who's come out of prison wrongly
convicted needs or even somebody who has
mental health issue before they're going
because but that's not factored in I was
very fortunate that I fell into another
institution the BBC and started a career
there that I didn't have time to see a
psychiatrist or a psychologist biggest
mistake I ever made because I think it
would have done me good what are those
scars you talk about psychological scars
what are the what are those scars I I I
think it's the things that we are
entitled to as human beings love emotion
being able to be
um open and honest with the person that
you love and care about being able to to
talk to the person that you love and
care about have open conversations and I
struggle with that now and have done
because I have been so protective of
what I say to people at fear that they
will miss
use that information to get me into
trouble or
um just having a conversation with
somebody that they turn that into
something that it wasn't he said this to
me when I didn't so there has been this
innate fear in me over the years I was
in prison and then I first got out of
prison
and there's also the the the inabilities
to do things make choices for yourself
that that are really challenging you
know I remember when I started my
relationship not long after I got out of
prison
um and I just couldn't make a decision
for myself I really struggled to make a
simple decisions for myself and felt
like a child again turning to the person
that I'm supposed to be developing a
relationship with a girlfriend
um and asking them things that they
laughed about at the beginning it was
quite funny because they kind of got it
that I'd been deprived of those
abilities for so long
but then it becomes quite quite
stressful quite challenging to be able
to stand there and sort of say you know
well what did I do I don't know what to
do because someone's always made those
decisions for me you know do I take them
curlyworthy or the marathon you you know
you think it's simple stuff that when
you've not been able to have a choice
because there was only one thing on
offer I.E you know happy baked beans as
opposed to Heinz baked beans and then
all of a sudden you've got happy baked
beans Heinz baked beans and all the
other bloody baked beans or all the
other coffees and you're used to one
being able to and I still struggle with
that I know people do in life struggle
with it but it's heightened when those
decisions are taken away and I liken it
to you know the lockdown period you know
people said to me oh God that lockdown
period just equivalent to being in
prison you do have a handle on the
inside of your bedroom door you can open
that door and walk out your bedroom door
you do have a handle on the inside of
your front door you can step outside in
prison I would never be never able to do
that and neither are other prisoners and
I'm not saying you should feel sorry for
people like that it's just let's not
compare things that are very different
and that's not me in the slightest Steve
saying that people that struggle during
the lockdown period and even now as a
result of covid and what it did to them
financially Etc I'm not undermining that
one little bit but what I am saying is
that those psychological challenges that
I had to overcome now I'm out of prison
and also running parallel to my new
developed career as a journalist
somebody who never held a mobile phone
until I come out of prison no no access
to the internet I'm gonna use a computer
never held a microphone did lots of
interviews with journalists but not on
the other side and and bluffing my way
initially with all these esteemed
journalists who'd spent their whole life
trying to get to where I got to within
12 months of getting out of prison what
does that say about the BBC I don't know
what I did have was determination what I
did have was this ability to look the
other man or woman in the eye who
thought that I wasn't good enough and
that I didn't have the skills or I
didn't have the appearance because I
still had my dreadlocks brown skin brown
eyes and dress very differently sounded
very differently not only did I have my
Southeast London accent
but I also had the prison slang that
came with that Southeast London accent
when I became a reporter on the radio
for today program where there are people
who say you can only be on that program
if you speak the queen's English I'm far
from speaking to queen's English my
vocabulary has changed over the years
but I was sitting alongside some people
who were supportive but they had a
difference it might have been that they
were gay and hide in their sexuality and
so there was a kind of Kindred that we
didn't even know we had but for some
reason they accepted me but as I say I
was often sort of
referred to in the media at that time as
this kind of convicted prisoner work in
in the BBC today program didn't matter
to me and I was very lucky that Greg
Dyke at the time was making big
statements about BBC being hideously
white and he was very supportive of the
fact that the BBC had had employed me
um and that helped after this remarkable
career you've had following
um following that day of your release in
terms of your journalistic career
working at the BBC then going on in and
having this Mega hit Netflix show that
everybody loves and that is short and
produced in a very original way in terms
of like empathy and such have we watched
it yes I've watched it yeah and most of
my team have watched it I think pretty
much all of them okay it's good and
they've um were in a car last week
watching it on the way to uh maybe on
the way back from the prison we're in we
will get we were spending the day in and
Holly and my team was yeah she's Holly
here today
oh excuse me yeah
she was
very excited to say the least at us
having this conversation today oh great
um
you travel all over the world going to
prisons meeting prisoners and seeing the
conditions what have you and also
reflecting on your own experience what
have you learned about the importance of
hope you know one of the things I wanted
to ask you was had you not take into
that typewriter and fought
and not accepted the the the sentence
would you still be sat there now knowing
what you know about the system
hope got me through prison hope when you
think about it here other people's
stories right
hear other people's
evidence
so there is an acronym for hope that we
can use
hear other people's experiences and
that's what I do that's what I do when I
go around the world making my Netflix
story I don't judge people
because I know what it's been like to be
judged
I hear other people's experience that's
where my hope comes from that's what I
give to people so long before I discover
that they are a serial killer in my
Netflix show long before I hear about
the cruel things wicked things that
they've been involved in or have
experienced in their own lives in terms
of trauma
I hear their stories I listen to what
they have to say without judgment I may
judge them after I've discovered what
they've done and I do on some occasions
or our sexual offenses in particular
but I don't judge someone because I've
been in that predicament where I've been
judged so many times and people have
reached the conclusion of who I am and
what I'm like long before they've even
had a conversation with me or taken the
time to discover what I'm really like as
opposed to what they read about me or
what they think about me and so you know
that's one of the things that that I
learned at the beginning when I started
to shoot the Netflix series and going
around the world in prison it wasn't an
easy thing to do you know I spent all
these years trying to get out of prison
as I've said many times so willing need
to go back in and it you know do this
for a television program
but I decided to do it because I want to
educate people when I was in the
isolation self strip naked bleeding and
bruised nobody heard my voice I screamed
and I shouted through the pain that I
was suffering nobody heard my voice when
I was even sitting in my cell my prison
uniform one telling people I was
innocent nobody heard my voice
what I've been able to do in this show
is
force people who watched the show to
hear other people's voice that's not
them questioning whether they're guilty
or innocent whether what they did is
good or bad it's just given a platform
in a secret world that we hear very
little of we have all these mythical
programs break in you know prison break
and and other you know Orange Is the New
blacks we have these programs that kind
of sensationalize or glorify what prison
could be like but the reality is sitting
down with a man who's done some horrific
things telling his story trying to
understand why they've done what they've
done and then finding the balance
between how you then rehabilitate
somebody like that is it possible but
also from the victim's point of view how
do you treat somebody once they've been
sent to prison for punishment should
they continue to be punished in prison
should they live in these inhumane
conditions where they're not fed or
they're not provided with the basic
human rights that we all are entitled to
whether you are a prisoner or not a
prisoner and that includes the staff
because people that go into these
environments to work
um you know they don't deserve to be
treated like sub-humans just because
they work in these environments but they
are yeah I've got a ton of respect for
them you know especially after visiting
that prison I I had a huge amount of
admiration for the staff that worked
there and what they they also
um go through and a lot of them had very
from the ones that I spoke to very
um Good Intentions as to why they'd
become come to work in the prison
which in many respects reminded me of
like many of the teachers I met when I
went undercover in a school and got to
meet them in teachers in rough areas
um but this this also led to your
foundation could you tell me what your
what Your objective is with your
foundation and what you're and why
I think it's it's simple I mean it came
about simply because having been to so
many prisons around the globe and have
been witnessed so much suffering that is
unnecessary you you know regardless of
what you think about prisoners and I
know there were lots of people out there
who think well they don't deserve any
better although surprisingly as a result
my Netflix show a lot of people have
written to me from all over the globe
saying oh my God I believe that they
should be locked up and the key should
be thrown away by having watched your
show I have a different perspective no
one should be treated like that no one
should be
etc etc so that in itself and all of the
messages I get are so positive I really
can't think of any messages that I've
had from people there are occasions of
course but 99.9 of the messages that I
get from people all over the globe ask
me how they can help what they can do in
my recent Moldova episode I interviewed
two guys one of them killed an elderly
lady and a young lady and the other one
killed a woman a police officer and I've
had an avalanche of messages from people
asking to send them gifts because they
talk about you know their older parents
having to look after them but they're
going to die soon and then they and
people ask and I'm thinking well there
is humanity so that's what my Foundation
is about it's about Humanity it's about
treating people
rehumanizing so we have this strap line
rethink re-humanize and reintegrate
and for me it's about the policy makers
and decision makers but also businesses
outside of these locations where these
prisons are getting involved to rethink
what the purpose of prison is and what
we can do to educate
or skill up train individuals that are
in prison that are not
being given these opportunities keys
because there is no resource to provide
these opportunities if you went along to
Charlton the other day you would have
witnessed programs and projects that
they're probably running with the
prisoners that may provide an
opportunity if these guys take these
opportunities to change their lives
Steve Trust Me In many of the places
that I've been around the world they
just do not exist people who have had
traumatic lives that have led to them
ending up in prison doing the things
that they do have no therapy or any help
they are not afforded any education to
address their offending Behavior which
means they are potentially going to
commit more crime when they get out of
prison and I think we should care about
that and we should try and do something
about that what can you do okay a hungry
man can be an angry man so if I'm going
into Papua New Guinea and there are
prisoners who can't be fed surely there
is a sustainable way because they have
the land and the in the prison surely
there is a way that we can teach them to
grow tomatoes or potatoes and they can
be self-sufficient so they can provide
for themselves why can't a local
business do that why can't they the
government do that so the foundation is
about rethinking the policies in prison
how to re-humanize the way we treat
prisoners I've seen some of the most
horrific videos that you would ever
imagine seeing and I could show you
these videos that prisoners have sent me
of
the murders that take place that they're
filming on mobile phones I mean how
dehumanizing and desensitizing is that
for a prisoner to send me a WhatsApp
message of a video as they are killing
someone in that very moment that is
barbaric and I'm saying why why would
another young man Like You video the
decapitating and the
what they're doing to other young men
for no other reason than they belong to
another gang or because they did and
I've seen quite a few of these videos
where riots were kicked off in certain
places that I've been to and I've met
these individuals and I'm thinking why
and it's simply because these young men
have never been told that gang life
violence is wrong and I mean that when I
say that because they don't have
therapists or psychologists or NGO
groups Charities working in these places
trying to address the issues that these
guys have experienced and then it comes
down to reintegration doesn't it you're
going to let these guys who are prepared
to kill in prison
back out into society where they've been
traumatized by what they've witnessed
and what I gathered in some of these
videos for example is you know one guy's
filming it and three or four guys five
guys are standing there you can see that
they don't want to take part in what is
taking place but they do because if they
don't they could become the next victim
and that is really sad to see and you
can see it in their eyes you can see it
in their Dominion so you can see them
taking the weapon and inflicting a blow
in a way that you can see they don't
really want to be inflicting that blow
so I've seen these things
firsthand in these environments in these
prisons around the world where they
don't have the means to make a
difference to change things and so I set
up the foundation off the back of the
things that I witnessed in these prisons
with an intention to try and
improve the opportunities for prisoners
staff and the conditions in prison so
for example
I was in a prison quite recently where
they are trying to encourage prisoners
to take up art but they don't have any
resources they don't have any materials
to provide so I'm sort of saying okay if
I can find somebody who's an artist who
can donate this
material to this prison and then we take
it a step further we use that art to
create art therapy where some of these
guys who would not otherwise step into a
therapeutic room could be encouraged to
go in there to do what they do which is
pain but also address some of the
traumatic experiences that they've been
through or have witness that makes them
the person that there are so there are
ways as I've just explained that you can
make a a difference and the authorities
want it you know I speak to the
directors of these prisons who encourage
me to come back and get involved in the
work that they're they're doing a pot of
pain you know some of these prisons are
so broken a pot of paint will make a
difference but you're also not just
giving them the pot of paint what you're
doing is you're asking a decorating firm
big decorating firm to take their skills
into a prison teach these guys to paint
properly so there is an opportunity for
them coming up to come and decorator now
that might not be everybody's ambition
when you don't have anything inside a
prison and that's what we're trying to
offer is opportunity Unity
and the other version of Hope to some of
these environments forgiveness is an
interesting word because it there's many
layers to forgiveness but when you look
back on your time in prison what
happened to you and the people that
conspired to put you there
some of them clearly very illegally
is it possible to get to a place of
forgiveness
I don't forgive anybody who did what
they did to me I never will never have
and have no intention of forgiving those
people they don't deserve my forgiveness
and I'm not a forgiving person in that
sense
um
and there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that is there
there's nothing wrong with me not
wanting to forgive someone
um
I can understand things
but I can't understand why someone would
tell a lie that destroys somebody else's
life
deliberately in the way that they did
mine
so I have no
intention in my heart or mind and that
doesn't make me a bad or a wrong person
I'm in my right not to forgive someone
for something that they did in the same
way that you know someone who thinks
they're in a solid relationship is
treated cheated on and they decide to
break up and they can't find
forgiveness for that person forgiveness
doesn't stop you moving on forgiveness
doesn't stop you becoming the person
that you have the potential to become
forgiveness is
a word actions in my book speak louder
than words to say I forgive you doesn't
really mean I forgive you it might make
you feel more comfortable and it might
help you release the burden of the guilt
that you felt for the wrong that you've
done
but for the person saying I forgive you
for many it will help of course it will
it will lift the guilt from them or lift
the burden of them being
strained by this hatred for somebody but
for me forgiveness is just a word and
nobody who did
took part in what happened to me give me
back my twenties they can't give me back
the fact that I couldn't have sex for
bloody 12 years even though I sneaked
one in that Chapel but they can't give
me back the things that were taken from
me because of what they'd done and so I
have no intention of forgiving those
people but that doesn't mean that I have
any animosity towards them or that I am
bitter towards them or that I'm angry
are you angry towards them at all
I'm not I I I'm I'm not angry towards
them in the sense that I would
want
something bad or anything like that
that's not what I can but of course I'm
still angry
about their role in what happened to me
the two police officers that
interrogating me the questions that you
asked me at the beginning you know the
fact that they
fabricated evidence made up stories and
and changed things to fit me into the
crime rather than accept that the
evidence was pointing away from me
um it makes me angry to think that they
did that Steve and that they were
prepared to do that to me
but I'm not angry any any more
um
took towards them in in a kind of way
that disturbs how I should be thinking
or behaving I don't give them the time
of day when I'm sitting here and talking
to you I'm talking to other people about
my experience of course there is this
heat that I talk about that kind of
warms my body my ears my mind because
I'm revisiting some of the experiences
that hurt me I'm revisiting some of
those experiences that changed who I
should have been even though as you say
the Silver Lining is I've gone on to
lead a successful career maybe that's
not who I should have been maybe I
should have been somebody else but I
would never find out who that somebody
else could have been maybe in those 12
years I was in prison I discovered a
love with my dad where hugging him and
kissing him on the cheek became natural
instead of it becoming something I
forced because I saw other people doing
that I had a question asked me which you
just reminded me about from a guy called
mogada they do this eraser test and it's
they asked people they said of the most
traumatic experience you've been enter
in your life of all the traumatic event
if you could press a button
and erase it
would you
now if I put a button in front of you
and said you press this button and it
raises
those 12 years
and it raises the the sentencing and all
that day those people that storm through
the door in the middle of the night and
arrested you would you press the button
would I press the button that would
erase who I am no
because that's what it's doing it's not
a raising
a a trauma is it is not erasing an
experience it's a raising who who I am
that's what you do when you press a
button like that you're raising the
person you are and I'd never raise who
who I am I'm proud of who I am
I'm pleased
about what I do who I become the people
that are in my life
my mission what I've earned what I've
lost
and to press that button I'd be erasing
all of that and I I wouldn't do that
even if it was to just erase that period
um
because I am who I am because of my life
experiences and the journey that I've
been on and the people that I've met
along the way things that I've witnessed
the things that I've learned
um about others and about myself I have
this um
this skill is how I'm gonna describe it
right we all have a skill of some kind
yours is making money running businesses
and having a brilliant podcast studio
and a great team right
I learned a skill and I alluded to it
earlier on where I read the character of
men for so long in such an intimate way
that it does put me in a position
of survival when I go into these prisons
when I look a guy in the eye who's
killed five ten people and I'm in a room
with him on my own or I'm interviewing
him and his behavior is characteristics
trust me when I say this
in the years that I was imprisoned I
think I met every type of character man
you could possibly meet you know because
not every prisoner is the same there are
guys in there who are entrepreneurs and
over millions of pounds but they killed
their wife in a moment of Madness there
are guys in there who came from Council
of States like me who got caught up in
knife crime and violence and drugs so
there are all types of prisoners you
know I've talked to various people who
are fraudsters who run you know
successful businesses whether it's Wall
Street or some new.com business I had a
guy on my podcast the other day lost
billions of pounds John le Frey who who
set up the first Nutella business
um which is the one of the very first
dot-coms before PayPal started and stuff
so I had him on my Second Chance podcast
the other day multi-zillion is still a
multi-zillionaire but he did end up in
prison so you come across all types of
characters in prison and that allows me
to do the work that I do in the
environment that I work in at the moment
which is probably the most important
piece of work that I've done in my whole
journalistic career so I'm not going to
raise anything that has given me the
tools to be the person I am love the way
I love care the way I care and make the
difference that I want to make
the
work you've done the Netflix series
you've produced
um and the work you continue to do is
incredibly important work because it's
shining a light and giving as you've
said giving a voice to people that don't
have that voice
um it's incredibly entertain
entertaining maybe to its detriment
because it becomes a bit binge-worthy
but I would highly recommend anyone that
hasn't seen it to go and watch it ASAP
on Netflix and I think uh you know
everyone's always scrimmaging around
trying to find a good Netflix series to
watch it's one of my very favorite and
the team here are just obsessed with it
absolutely obsessed with it um outside
of that your foundation is feels like
it's there's a little bit of almost
coincidence to me meeting you after all
the things I've described well that
depends what comes with this guy exactly
but I love I love the idea listen you're
a man who's successful right and you've
taken some time out of your day to go
into a prison to talk to guys you don't
even realize the impact that you
probably made because these are guys
that have probably never been in a space
like the space that you shared with them
or heard somebody and I know you've got
a bit of a backstory yourself which is
why Steve's coming on my podcast but you
have a little bit of a backstory where
you know you wasn't born with a silver
spoon or a gold spoon in your mouth you
know I know I don't know your story and
I don't want to know until you share it
with me because I think that's the best
way of learning something if you've got
a book I might be tempted to this or I
can inform myself but I discover and and
so you know it's great to hear that
you've taken the time to go into a
prison to find out what that's like it
is a secret world but it is a world that
holds people like you and me Brothers
Sons you know husbands
um lovers and potential for being all
those things as well guys that are
dependent on drugs more importantly many
prisoners suffer from mental health
issues and those issues are not being
addressed if the resources are not being
put into those places to address those
issues so I admire the fact that you
know you're not just watching Netflix
and inside the world's toughest prisons
and me getting stripped or threatened or
whatever but you're taking to timeout of
your busy schedule as is your team to go
into it because whatever your motive I
don't care what the motive is the fact
that you've gone in there and learned
something come away felt this burden on
your shoulder Goosebumps just because
the description you know leaving there
it was I I was I was I had a weird thing
say silent but I remember the day after
posting to my team and just saying I
need to do something about this but it
was it was overwhelming I think is the
feeling that's a good way to describe it
I was overwhelmed to the point of
Silence because I you know for the
reasons I said earlier when I when when
you asked me about my foundation and I
say to you look this is what I'm trying
to do what do you think about something
where people are trying to help people
or the environment oh my God like I'm
all for it
I for whatever reason have a bias to
helping those that are struggling them
the most and regardless of why they're
struggling I when I went undercover in a
school in Liverpool I got a lot of flack
because the kid that I warmed to and
ultimately made a big donation to and
provided you know an opportunity to was
the kid that was doing really badly and
everyone's like well why didn't you help
the people that are getting straight A's
I took to this young kid called Stephen
who wanted to be successful didn't have
a father was a like a in school was
about to get kicked out always in the
exclusion area and I remember looking on
Twitter and seeing all this like oh why
did he help the the the you know the kid
that's down at counted out that's so
when I went to this prison for me as
you've described the word Humanity
um I saw past all of that stuff and it
was just like a bun especially from
doing this podcast you learned that the
the home life the the foundation the
environment that people grow up in that
puts them there that leads to them being
there and that's what I see in these
people it was like you know I saw the
potential and I saw the all the good
stuff and all the the negative stuff
really doesn't matter to me it well I
find it harder to see naturally so
that's why I felt like this burden
because you know the kid that given me
as bit as business plan I'm looking
through this and going this is just
amazing if he just had a different
father if he just had a different mother
if he just grew up in the home that I
grew up in It's A Better or For Worse he
you know he I said to the kid I went you
this is a better business plan than I've
ever done in my life and I've made
hundreds of millions in business and
this is a and I meant it I wasn't I was
like I've never made a business plan
that is 97 pages long and that has all
this so
um that was why I felt overwhelmed
because it was almost I was scared at
the loss of potential and talent and how
that would cause a generational loss in
potential and talent and I wanted to do
something about it not knowing what I
can do about it I saw small things which
we can talk about but
um you know as it relates to skills and
upskilling people and really I didn't
feel like the prison was teaching them
um they're teaching them some amazing
things which blew me away but as it
relates to like I run a creative
business right now if you could train
five people to do this particular thing
I will hire them I don't care you know
um and it was actually talking about
video editing funnily enough they
weren't learning video editing and they
said well we've not got anyone here that
can teach the video editing we can't
hire video editors fast enough in all my
companies it's a no-brainer isn't it I
was saying to them please can you start
teaching these people video editing and
then I'll take them and they were like
would you take I'll say yes I'll we'll
take them from the from the prison when
they're released
the last thing I want to talk to you
about is love
because you found love shortly after
leaving prison
you're married
you have
um two wonderful children with her
what what does this person mean to you
what has she done for your life through
all of that Journey you've been on the
psychological challenges you faced
um with coming back into society after
your your sentence and the journey
you've been on thereafter
I think my love story is is not after
prison it actually started long before I
actually went to prison because the
woman that I married
was a girlfriend before I got wrongfully
arrested convicted and imprisoned
um you know we were both teenagers when
we first met and
um at that point in her life she did
have all the things that I didn't have
ambition she was you know Edgar at
school she was destined to go to
university she was learning different
languages she went on holiday I hadn't
even left South East London you know my
first time on a plane at 32 going to I
think it was future Ventura I saw the
waves splashing and thought it was
sharks that's I was 32 years old that's
how naive I was so Nancy is her name and
we had a very brief relationship just
before I got locked up
and during the time that I was on remand
she came to visit me in a horrible
environment you know I was a category a
prisoner which meant anybody come and
visit me got strip search search to
visit me so she endured quite a lot at
such a young age she stuck by me in that
early period where everybody was telling
lies
when I was convicted big decisions
needed to be made obviously she needed
to get on with the rest of her life I
was destined to spend the rest of mine
in in prison and that's exactly what
happened but I did have a picture one
picture of her
alongside my family on my wall whenever
I stayed in a Cell long enough to stick
it up there
and you know she was a teenager and she
remained a teenager in all those 12
years as did I you know although I was
32 when I got out and she was now in her
late 20s
um
I was still
caught up in being 20 years old but
given she was only one of a very few
people who didn't turn against me didn't
tell lies stood firm not because she was
a tough resilient person but because she
wasn't telling lies she wasn't persuaded
she comes from a good family who
obviously didn't want to have very much
to do with me now
so when I came out of prison Steve there
was a handful of people I wanted to say
thank you to and we talked about thank
you and great so I arranged to meet with
Nancy despite her
wanting to meet me and people in her
family not wanting her to meet me
because they thought I would just bring
bad to her again because she went
through a real tough time and I don't
ever know what that must have been like
for her because she was interrogated by
the police as was many other people that
were associated with me at the time and
that must have been very traumatic for
them themselves
but we agreed to meet in London Bridge
where she was working at the time and we
did meet and um when I saw her and she
saw me
it was as if those 12 years didn't
happen yet we both aged I'd matured
um she was still the very focused
determined person that she is
and smart and clever and beautiful and
sexy and all the things that make you
attracted to an individual and I tried
to chatter up I think I tried to chat
her up again in the same way I tried to
chat on when we were teenagers didn't
quite work because after we'd spent some
time together and it was really
interesting because I was her first love
and although she'd gone on to live her
life and have relationships
I don't think you ever lose your love
for the first person you love I don't
know because I'd never been in love up
until that point you know I never I'm 32
and I've never been in love
um
after that brief meeting we said goodbye
ask for a number like you do and um she
wouldn't give me a number
I'm still just discovering how mobile
phones work but anyway I I um
answer a number she wouldn't give me her
number
she had my number and then we were on
London Bridge platform I was on one side
of the platform going one way she was on
I was living in East London at the time
and she was on the other platform going
south London and then you know kind of
way even before the trains come and
across the platforms this is genuine
across the platforms my phone went ping
I opened my phone and it was a number so
and she was standing there on her phone
and she sent me her number
at that moment and
um
that's when we started another little
bit of a relationship so we kind of had
this Whirlwind you know I was still
trying to live it up I was kind of
wanting to go clubs and do all the
things that you do that you've missed
out on or thought that you'd missed out
on she'd had all that in a university
years
um study in German and French at
University
and that's how our love began actually
our relationship we started to see each
other spent more time as you come to
spend more time at my flat and then we
bought a house together
um and I fell in love I fell in love for
the very first time at 32 years old
I think I'd always been in love with her
because she was so different to any
other woman girl that I'd ever met in my
life
um and by that I go back to that growing
up in a council of state where no one
around me had any ambition girls or boys
no parent had any ambition no word like
University existed in our all bit but
she was the first person I'd met in my
life
before I went to prison where university
did mean something education did mean
something aspirations of having a job
meant something to her and it was the
same when I met her only this time I'd
heard of those things I was aware of
those things and now it made sense why
she was driven in that way so we started
that relationship and and we started
lived together and then she felt
pregnant with my son
um and then we went to Jamaica got
married and as I say she's probably the
first and only woman I've ever loved
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest
um they don't know who they're leaving
it for the question that's been left for
you is
what is a mistake that you know you've
made that you can fix but you haven't
yet fixed
I think it's going back to the question
of my son I think the mistake I made
um
was maybe walking out of that courtroom
and
and and giving up on
on what I should have done I think that
might have been a mistake although I
know it was the right decision at the
time but the consequences of my actions
on that day
has meant that I've never been able to
discover anything about my son so if I
could correct that mistake that would be
the one I I think to go back and see
what would have come of that it would
have been lovely to be able to to hand
these Diaries over to my son although
now you can probably read my book so the
Diaries probably are are worthless
um but they are more to him so I think
that would be the mistake I would go
back and and correct
thank you so much for your time and
thank you so much for everything you've
created and I say that because there is
a lot that you've created in your books
in the podcast and your Netflix shows
and everything that came before that as
a journalist
um it's such an important work but I
know that it can't always be easy you
even talked about the heat that you feel
sometimes when you reflect on these
really traumatic experiences I know it
can't be easy but the value that that it
brings to Enlighten people who it
wouldn't ever you know have the you know
that they're privileged enough to never
end up in prison or to be in those
environments but to just shine a light
on that I think creates a huge amount of
empathy across the world as it does for
me when I've watched your show and I've
read your your book and I've had this
conversation with you today
um and that empathy can only be a good
thing and that's work that could not be
more important so thank you so much and
thank you for an amazing conversation
um thank you for the inspiration and I
I'm fully behind you and your mission
because it's an incredibly important one
thank you I do appreciate you saying
that and I'll leave you with this
thought
when we make mistakes in life it doesn't
Define who who we can become and anybody
could end up in prison you get and leave
me today you get into your car you pull
out and before you know it you have an
accident that was no fault of your own
but the person in the car that you
crashed dies you end up going to prison
for manslaughter that doesn't make you a
bad person doesn't make you guilty of
something that you intend to do or
anything like that so all I'm trying to
say is that message is don't judge
somebody because of what they've done
there are plenty of people that you can
judge for what they've done but in my
space you know criminal justice prisons
um not everybody in there is a bad
person some people have just made
mistakes and I think every time you make
a mistake whether you cheat on someone
do what you shouldn't be doing
um you shouldn't be punished for that
um in the way that some people are being
punished around the globe in prison so
thanks for having me on and I appreciate
your being inspired by who I am and what
I do as I am you of course and I know
lots of other people are because when I
say I'm going to have a chat with this
guy Steve Bartlett on Diary here which
I've listened to on numerous occasions
it's like oh my God so you you you know
you're a successful guy but there are
lots of people out there who are
inspired what you do and you know that
because of the way you interact and the
people that
but we must never underestimate
um the position we're in to influence
people to help other people
amen amen thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh